but it's in martin they were welcomed into
our school right away and we
immediately made them meet their
classmates it was a
very nice welcome moment because the
children immediately identified
the beauty of having them with them the
school became a second family
for  i bambini is also a
place of friendship for the mother who in
any case would be here alone and
precisely so that these children can
understand that the tear that
has occurred which is very strong does not mean not
returning to their own land anymore free school
in a  country like italy in a city
like varese but like any other
city it
means going forward not interrupting
one's school journey with the
hope of being able to continue it and
finish in their country of origin